all right boom yesterday
the united states of america greatest
country on earth
yes played in the concacaf final
okay which is basically a soccer
tournament amongst like all the uh
like teams in north america and like
central america and like the caribbean
and ship
yeah they played mexico in the final and
won basically at the same time as the
floyd mayweather fight so a lot of
people missed it right but it was
arguably like the most absurd
game why it was just chaos
so basically the game went full 90
minutes usa and mexico also were just
like rivals in this division
so like they're the two biggest teams or
the two best teams they go back and
forth winning
losing that kind of thing and they
played in denver but the thing is when
you play a game
versus mexico in america a soccer game
it's basically mexican
home field advantage every time because
mexicans no matter where you are they're
coming out to the game
yeah and then americans are kind of like
oh yeah we'll go if we can so like no
matter if you're playing to
burst mexico in america you're playing
50 in front of mexican fans no matter
what so there's no real like home field
advantage
so they're playing in denver and the
game is just absolutely absurd from like
start to finish there's like
dirty plays there's the game goes full
90 minutes then it goes an extra
additional time
they add extra time at the end they stop
the game
because there's homophobic chants in the
audience yes which this is actually an
interesting thing
like culturally speaking because soccer
players are the gayest athletes yeah
and mexicans are the most homophobic
yeah exactly so you get the two together
like what's happening that's why they
have the fence there so they don't beat
them up yeah um no but
they're building a wall no but basically
they start
doing this homophobic chant in like the
90th minute and they add a bunch of
extra time because they stop the game
what was the chant
so they don't have the exact chant but
basically they were saying
puto and this that's where it gets weird
because
they just call it a male it's a male
[ __ ]
but apparently there's a translation
that kind of translates to we use it in
the same way that we would use the word
maggot with an f but it's
it translates literally to male [ __ ]
yeah because bhuta is [ __ ]
so you're a puto so it's used in the
same way but
it's not literally the same word right
right okay and so then they stop the
game so apparently like a bunch of these
federations have put in this rule where
there's a homophobic chant or a racist
chant they stop the game
okay and then they put like a penalty on
the audience basically
which is kind of like a wild rule that i
don't know if it exists in other sports
how's that a penalty on the audience
because they say i'm just match we're
not we're not playing the game until you
guys stopped was the only way to like
the true die hard fans like in europe
like was the only way to like
how do you really threaten them how do
you penalize the audience like they're
not playing
because you don't play the game yeah now
you can't watch the game they paid money
to watch the game and if they continue
to chant we're just going to knock it
out you're giving
the audience too much power because now
my team's behind or say they look winded
and [ __ ] like that oh let's just start
some races [ __ ] yeah give them a little
time out and then they back into [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's what some people are
saying they might have been doing
because in the 90th minute
game was tied up and then they started
this chant and they're like all right
what's happening
okay so then what happens so it goes
into extra time christian pulisic
the legend the legend scores a penalty
kick in like the 116th minute okay puts
the team ahead
and then right before that the american
goalkeeper got subbed out because he got
injured
so they put in the substitute keeper
who's like from denver like grew up
there
and then like five minutes left in the
game mexico gets a pk he saves it
okay he saves it like off the line like
the most absurd thing ever there's like
a streaker that runs on the field
there's another goal that mexico scored
that they took back like
the game just had everything there were
fights like crazy about this story
they were throwing bottles and shots oh
yeah that's nate like that's the other
thing i don't get
how can we always talk about basketball
players like one person throws popcorn
at them and it's like the biggest deal
in the world everyone's like crying
they're going
through popcorn or whatever because
those are actual athletes
and then at the start game they're
literally at the corner one of the best
players in the men's team got hit in the
head with a bottle
like a glass bottle hit him in the head
and then they kept playing you know what
the wildest part of that is
i still don't want to watch soccer yeah
like like
that was just the craziest match ever
that sounds crazy yo yeah i like it
you gotta watch good soccer football i
like it i still think it's cool
i just want to know who were they
calling a [ __ ] that on the americans
and what was he doing and was he being a
[ __ ] yeah because all those soccer
players are some people
like that yeah always grabbing their
ankle and then playing two minutes later
there's a bunch of right they are
grabbing their ankles
grab their ankles yeah i don't know i
think that's some puto [ __ ] but anytime
america wins i'm about it so this is
awesome
shout out to christian pulisic we got to
have him on the podcast he's a rising
star huh
he wanted just one recently won the
champions league a week ago
for chelsea yeah and now which is a
neighborhood for putos
so maybe they were right maybe it worked
out the whole time